pouvoir commencer cette audition
alors donc nous recevons ce matin des
représentants des fédérations
hospitalières au sujet de l'évolution du
financement des établissements de santé
alors lundi
que cette audition fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo retransmise en direct
sur le site du Sénat et qui sera ensuite
disponible en vidéo à la demande nous le
savons le président de la République a
annoncé lors de ses vœux professionnels
de santé pour le mineur 2023 je cite une
sortie de la tarification à l'activité
dès le prochain prochain dès le prochain
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour aller vers un
nouveau financement qu'on doit rebâtir
sur la base d'un travail en profondeur
et d'une concertation qui repose sur une
rémunération basée sur des objectifs de
santé publique
ami année il est donc important de faire
le point sur l'état de ce chantier qui
ne pourra qu'avoir de fortes
conséquences pour les hôpitaux qu'ils
soient publics ou privés ainsi que sur
la concertation en cours et nous avons
le plaisir d'accueillir pour la
Fédération hospitalière de France la FHF
madame Cécile chevance qui est
responsable du pôle of
de soins finance FHF data recherche
e-santé vous êtes déjà auditionné pour
les données de santé la fédération de
l'hospitalisation
privée donc la mine gardée n'est pas là
mais elle est représentée par Béatrice
Noella et Christine schumelin et la
Fédération des établissements
hospitaliers d'aide à
la personne privée solidaire l'a fait
voilà dans la délégation qu'on dit par
Monsieur Charles Desprat qui est
directeur général de la ferap et unique
cancer dans la délégation est conduite
par Madame Sophie Beaupain délégué
général donc je vous propose de
commencer cette audition par un propos
liminaire de préférence relative membre
afin de laisser toutes leurs places aux
échanges qui suivront parce que nous le
doute qu'il y aura beaucoup d'échanges à
une commissaire soit rapporteur soit
connaisseur de la T2A mais c'est pas
président 1000 euros donc voilà alors
qui commence la FHF allez-y madame
chevance
je vous remercie bonjour donc c'est les
chevaux au titre de la de la FHF tout
d'abord merci pour cette audition sur un
sujet important qui nous préoccupe tous
je m'excuse à l'avance pour les
collègues parce que en ce moment on fait
pas mal de d'intervention et d'audition
sur cette thématique donc on répète
évidemment beaucoup les mêmes choses
donc on commence à connaître nos propos
respectifs par cœur donc ça va être
évidemment encore les les forcément les
mêmes principes qu'on va qu'on va
rappeler donc peut-être dire
en propos liminaire les
prérequis qui pour la FAF sont
extrêmement importants les prérequis de
cette réforme du financement du MCO qui
succède à des réformes récentes ou en
cours sur les activités de SMR et de et
de psychiatrie donc nous avions posé
trois prérequis puisque la réforme du
financement du système de santé est un
sujet qui nous préoccupe depuis depuis
longtemps et sur lequel on fait des
propositions premier prérequis c'est que
ça s'inscrive dans un schéma de pluri
annualité donc de lisibilité pour les
établissements de santé donc ça puisse
s'appuyer sur une loi de programmation
en santé qu'on appelle de nos vœux qui
posent effectivement les priorités de
santé publique si possible assez
restreinte parce que quand on a 200
objectifs c'est difficile de les suivre
et de les observer tous donc quelques
priorités fondamentales de santé
publique et puis un protocole de
plurianolétique comme vous le savez a
déjà on a déjà eu un premier protocole
de 2020 à 2022 mais il a pris fin en fin
d'année dernière et nous n'avons pas de
renouvellement à ce jour de protocoles
de pluralité des ressources donc premier
principe la pluralité deuxième prérequis
qui rejoint d'ailleurs le premier c'est
que cette réforme s'appuie sur une
refondation des règles de construction
et de régulation de l'ONDA mais qui a
déjà démarré il y a eu pas mal de
travaux tissu et d'ailleurs vous avez
travaillé au Sénat sur ces sur ces
sujets le bershkam a fait un certain
nombre de propositions et pour nous
cette régulation cette construction de
l'ONDAM doit s'appuyer sur aussi une
logique de plurianité et décliner
effectivement ensuite annuellement les
priorités de santé publique et c'est
pour ça qu'on a on a proposé dans le
cadre des travaux du HKM
une réserve plus ryanuelle pour pouvoir
lisser et réguler dans le temps les
aléas qu'on peut avoir au niveau annuel
aujourd'hui l'ONDA mais réguler de façon
annuelle voire infra annuelle avec une
forte incertitude pour les
établissements de santé sur leurs
ressources finales on a les dernières
notifications de crédit en mars avril de
l'année suivante donc l'année éclose
donc ça c'est absolument ingérable pour
un établissement de santé d'avoir cette
incertitude sur plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros en plus on n'est pas
sur des sur des sommes négligeables loin
de là
a priori au vu des premiers échanges
qu'on avait eu avec la mission
IGAS ça semble plutôt bien parti en tout
cas pour qu'il reprenne ils sont très à
l'écoute sur ses propositions et qui
reprennent ces propositions ce qui
préjuge en rien évidemment des décisions
qui sont prises ensuite mais c'est déjà
une première étape troisième prérequis
c'était que comme l'annoncé le président
de la République et comme la reprise
ensuite le ministre de la Santé ça soit
une réforme systémique qui concerne
l'ensemble du système de santé et
l'ensemble des acteurs notamment en
termes de modulation
à des objectifs et des résultats en
termes de santé publique ce qui nous
motive tous on voit pas tellement
comment des acteurs seuls peuvent avoir
les leviers pour agir sur la santé des
populations et c'est tous ensemble tout
acteur de tout statut public privé
lucratif ou non et libéraux qu'on pourra
effectivement avoir une véritable action
sur les indicateurs de santé publique
sachant qu'en termes de d'espérance de
vie en bonne santé on n'est pas
forcément les plus performants en France
on est bon en espérance de vie en
espérance de vie sans incapacité on est
moins bon que certains de nos voisins
très proches sans le temps qu'on
consacre plus d'argent qu'ils consacrent
eux plus d'argent ça pas forcément un
lien avec les dépenses le montant des
dépenses de santé au prorata du PIB donc
et là pour l'instant ça s'engage pas
bien puisque la mission est ignf elle
est en appui à la d.o.s donc son seul
périmètre c'est les établissements de
santé donc on a l'impression qu'on nous
refait un petit peu la même chose qu'au
moment de ma santé 2022 notamment sur
les forfaits pathologiques qui devaient
concerner l'ensemble des acteurs de
santé et finalement on s'est retrouvé
seul établissement de santé à la table
des discussions et c'est vrai que sur
les pathologies chroniques sur des
grands indicateurs de santé publique on
peut pas faire du bon travail si il y a
que certains acteurs qui n'ont pas tous
les leviers pour agir autour de la table
donc ça c'est c'est on trouve assez
dommage parce qu'en terme de modulation
sur des indicateurs de santé publique on
aura on aura du mal à agir seul ou en
tout cas on va restreindre notre action
sur les seuls objectifs sur lesquels on
est on a tous les leviers donc ça va
restreindre quand même beaucoup le
l'ambition et l'ampleur du du
et peut-être rappelé au dernier point en
propos liminaire que les hôpitaux
publics sont dans une situation un petit
peu particulière puisque le tout réduire
le tout est de ça ou le tout est de za
n'a pas tellement de signification à
l'hôpital public puisque nous sommes
déjà dans une mixité très large de
financement nous n'avons jamais été en
tout état puisque nous avons un
financement au forfait à la dotation aux
missions migaques aux missions
d'enseignement de recherche et
d'innovation très très important donc
quand on prend le financement à
l'activité au sens large pas seulement
l'activité médicalisée du PMSI et des
séjours on est à 60% à peu près aide
financement à l'activité en moyenne
c'est une moyenne si on prend vraiment
stricto ceinture les recettes séjour
liées à la T2A on est à 37% en moyenne
alors c'est une moyenne ça dépend
beaucoup de la taille et de l'activité
des établissements c'est vrai pour les
gros établissements comme les CHUS ou
les gros ch moins vrai pour les plus
petits établissements qui sont plus
sensibles effectivement aux aléas de la
T2A mais voilà bien prendre en compte
cette situation tout à fait spécifique
des hôpitaux publics
merci on va faire dans l'ordre la ferme
bonjour et merci de nous donner
l'occasion de nous exprimer aujourd'hui
alors je rejoins pas mal de propos de la
FHF notamment sur la notion de pluri
annualité et de programmation qui est
une notion essentielle pour avoir un peu
de visibilité de lisibilité dans le dans
le système moi je voudrais insister sur
quelques points qui sont importants pour
notre fédération et je pense qu'on
partage sinon le le constat des
modifications de des règles de
financement sont indispensables
aujourd'hui le premier point
concernerait
[Musique]
le financement des missions de service
public nos établissements les espics
donc établissement de santé privée
d'intérêt collectif ont un très grand
nombre de missions en commun avec les
établissements publics de santé et
pourtant sur certaines missions on peut
parler notamment de la permanence des
soins le financement de ces missions est
assez hétérogène et nous sommes très en
attente d'une modification du
financement de ces missions et peut-être
par la même soyons un peu ambitieux
d'une réforme de définition des missions
de service public qui sont dévolués aux
établissements quel que soit leur statut
leur nature puisque nous participons
tous à l'accueil de patients non
programmés avec des restes à charge à 0
ou des tarifs des tarifs opposables donc
on a on a en ligne de mire cette cette
question qui est importante pour nous
partager aussi que si on devait
supprimer le tout est de Zab
effectivement y pour les expliques on y
était pas nous non plus alors on est sur
des proportions beaucoup plus
importantes que ce qui a été rappelé de
l'ordre de 65 à 70%
T2A pour autant ce n'est pas le seul
mode de financement et nous sommes
évidemment intéressés à une nouvelle
ventilation je le disais à la fois sur
les missions de service public mais
aussi sur le financement des objectifs
de santé publique alors on cite les
maladies les maladies chroniques des
objectifs de responsabilité
populationnelle alors ce sont des sujets
qui sont intéressants et qui et sur
laquelle la FEA et les établissements
souhaitent s'engager on a effectivement
besoin un peu de visibilité lisibilité
sur ces sur ces sujets et notamment sur
les règles de fixation de ces objectifs
qui ne doivent pas être que des règles
locales ou des discussions locales mais
avec un cadre national connu et une
méthodologie qui soit partagée entre les
régions pour éviter des situations trop
hétérogènes
enfin dire que la CAP est évidemment
favorable à des modifications de la T2A
en elle-même on a parlé de sujets de
financement
hybride entre entretien des plateaux
techniques soit non programmés qui sont
pas exactement la pdfes qui sont des
financements pour équilibrer des
activités qui ne peuvent pas l'être
puisque on demande à certains
établissements de rester ouvert ou
d'avoir des capacités même quand ils
n'ont pas d'activité ça fait partie des
sujets qui nous intéressent et le sujet
de la réforme de la T2A en elle-même
avec un retour à une vision plus
tarifaire et de partir des coûts pour
définir les tarifs est un sujet qui l'a
encore nous intéresse nous intéresse
beaucoup et je finirai en ouvrant un peu
effectivement en tant que fédération
aussi très médico-social dire que la
césure entre le sanitaire et le
médico-social au sein un peu surannés il
serait important d'arriver à créer des
ponts plus significatifs alors sans même
parler de la médecine de ville mais en
tout cas des ponts entre les univers
sanitaires et médico-sociaux
très bien la FHP qui commence je vais
prendre la parole merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup de nous avoir invité à cette
audition avec un sujet qui est
absolument majeur donc c'est vrai que en
fait nous on pense que les réformes de
financement doivent être des outils au
service d'une stratégie de santé c'est
la réforme financement en soi n'a pas de
n'a pas d'intérêt elle doit servir des
objectifs stratégiques et dans les
objectifs stratégiques qui seraient un
peu le socle et en complément de ce qu'a
dit aussi de chevance que nous
partageons totalement sur la
plurianalité sur la refondation de la
régulation de lambda mais sur la une
réforme systémique je souhaitais
insister sur quelques sujets qui nous
tiennent à cœur donc la refonte du
service public hospitalier vers un
service de public de santé inclusif en
fait on a on sait tous que on a tous on
partage tous un certain nombre de
missions pour offrir des soins à
l'ensemble des publics sur les
territoires et il nous paraît demande de
baser ce socle une reconnaissance des
acteurs de tout statuts dans leur
mission
on a on a des personnels des équipes qui
sont en nombre très importantes puisque
au niveau de la FHP ça représente 150
000 salariés et 40 000 médecins libéraux
or en fait comme les autres collègues du
privé il n'y a pas de prise en compte
systématique des revalorisations
salariales qui soient financé pour nos
salariés ce qui pose un problème puisque
à chaque fois on est amené à discuter
plusieurs mois avec les collègues de du
nicancer et de la féap pour obtenir des
financements pour que nos salariés
puissent bénéficier d'augmentation or je
rappelle qu'on a 92% des de nos
ressources qui sont des ressources qui
sont octroyées par l'assurance maladie
redéfinition des missions des ARS pour
les conforter dans un rôle de régulateur
équitable dans un contexte
régionalisation des politiques donc ça
c'est aussi une dimension qui est
importante et mise en oeuvre de
véritables démocraties territoriales
la période est particulière en fait
aujourd'hui puisque on avait un
environnement on va dire assez stable en
termes de contexte jusqu'à il y a 4-5
ans mais maintenant on est un contexte
qui est marqué par l'inflation une
pénurie de ressources humaines qui
accrue une succession de crise et des
réformes des autorisations de
planification etc donc aujourd'hui on on
est nous tout à fait intéressé bien sûr
pour travailler sur sur une réforme mais
on pense que au-delà des prérequis qui
ont été rappelés par la FAF tout à
l'heure et que nous partageons il y a
des priorités stratégiques qui doivent
être
décrites et puis un travail
méthodologique sur la réforme qui soit
en rupture avec ce que nous connaissons
actuellement sur la réforme du smmr et
de la psychiatrie qui se font vous le
savez dans la douleur puisque
maintenant nous sommes le 5 juillet donc
la réforme du SMS s'est mise en place
pour le temps il n'y a toujours pas de
simulation
stabilisée et aujourd'hui pour donner
l'exemple du SMR et illustrer mon propos
sur la nécessité de fixer des objectifs
d'avoir une lisibilité pour les
établissements et puis après avoir une
méthode de conduite des réformes
notamment très en lien avec de
l'outillage de la discussion et les
régions aujourd'hui sur les CMR pour
donner juste cet exemple et en finir là
mon propos liminaire vous dire que la
simulation donc version 3 que nous avons
reçue il y a une quinzaine de jours
montre pour les établissements SSR de de
la FHP adhérent à la FHP une perte de
recettes de 30 millions d'euros soit
1,1% de leur recette nous représentons
42% de l'activité nationale du SMS et
contre toute attente puisque il
s'agissait de valoriser les activités
très spécialisées des SMS
une une un sous-financement absolument
majeur qui va remettre en cause
l'existence de certaines filières
spécialisées je donne juste deux
chiffres sur un groupe qui possède 40
établissements smmr il y a une perte de
23,5 millions d'euros donc c'est
colossal et ça va remettre en cause s'il
y a pas un ajustement la pérennité de
certaines activités et puis un autre
établissement qui appartient un petit
groupe qui est un établissement
extrêmement spécialisé dans la région de
Granville qui est un court très gros
établissement et qui perd 10% de ses
recettes avec la V3 or en fait c'est un
établissement spécialisé en euro
notamment et il assure deux tiers des
sorties de la prise en charge des
patients à l'issue des soins qu'ils ont
pu toucher au CHU de Caen donc c'est
juste pour illustrer les difficultés
donc c'est vrai que la réforme il faudra
qu'elle prenne en compte des objectifs
une stratégique une visibilité et un
travail sur les simulations qui soient
beaucoup plus concertées et beaucoup
plus anticipées pour pas se retrouver
dans la situation que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui comme par exemple en SMS où
on a une très grande difficulté avec des
inquiétudes majeures sur la pérennité
des établissements et ça ça pose un
problème parce qu'en fait quand il y a
des questionnements comme ça ou des
réformes qui prennent trop de temps dans
leur élaboration et de leur mise en
oeuvre ben en fait la traduction sur le
terrain c'est un blocage total des
investissements puisque les opérateurs à
défaut de visibilité sur la façon dont
ils sont rémunérés demain ou
après-demain et ben mettre en attente
les investissements et et ça pose
problème voilà donc c'était juste ce que
je voulais dire en propoliminaire en
nous vous remercions merci alors qui
parle pour unique cancer Sophie
beau-père
bonjour merci de pouvoir effectivement
nous permettre de nous exprimer sur ce
sujet si important pour notre fédération
je vais reprendre ce qu'on dit mes
collègues sur l'importance de la plus
ryanualité c'est vrai que c'est
fondamental par exemple concernant la
prévention concernant l'innovation de
pouvoir avoir une vision pluriannuelle
c'est cela qui permet d'avoir une
véritable vision stratégique comme cela
a été souligné nous sommes donc
favorables à la fois une loi de
programmation qui permettrait de pouvoir
avoir cette vision et de dégager des
orientations stratégiques à la fois
aussi nous sommes en attente d'un
protocole de plurianualité qui nous a
été présenté la semaine dernière dans le
cas d'apprentation de la réforme comme
pouvant être réinstrée en 2025 ce qui
paraît un petit peu tard compte tenu des
attentes et des besoins de nos
établissements comme la souligner
Charles geprat les CLCC sont des
expliques qui exercent des missions de
service public rappelons qu'ils sont
100% service public
activité libérale et aujourd'hui les
centres de luttes contre le cancer
pardon et aujourd'hui il y a une forte
forte crispation des professionnels sur
le fait que il n'y a pas d'équité
tarifaire entre les centres le cancer et
les hôpitaux publics rappelons que le
différentiel tarifaire il y a un
coefficient de minoration qui est
appliqué à nos tarifs aujourd'hui qui
est de moins 2,73% presque moins 3%
entre les tarifs de l'hôpital public et
ce décembre de lutte contre le cancer et
en même temps il y a une tension inédite
sur les ressources humaines et une
crispation très très forte au quotidien
dans nos établissements et nous sommes
donc favorables à ce que la mission de
service public également nous pouvions
nous puissions bénéficier du même
traitement et des mêmes et des mêmes
financements
notamment sur également la
revalorisation des gardes et astreintes
pour lesquelles les professionnels des
centres dont pour cette sorte n'ont pas
pu bénéficier alors même qu'il y a une
continuité des soins qui assurée par les
centres de lutte contre le cancer pour
leur patient 20% des séjours en centre
de lutte contre le cancer sont des
séjours pour des patients non programmés
qui sont accueillis donc la nuit et ce
pourcentage bien sûr ne fait que
progresser compte tenu de l'augmentation
de la prise en charge ambulatoire en
cancérologie qui évidemment un mouvement
un mouvement de fond encore faut-il que
nos établissements puissent accueillir
dans des bonnes conditions les patients
non programmés si on développe
l'ambulatoire ça effectivement c'est
donc pour nous la deuxième priorité la
troisième priorité c'est le fait de
pouvoir faire évoluer encore davantage
le système de financement vers un
financement véritablement au parcours de
soins pourquoi parce que cela colle
évidemment aux évolutions scientifiques
et techniques en particulier en
cancérologie dans l'ensemble des
maladies chroniques et et donc c'est ce
financement au parcours sous forme de
forfait qui va permettre de pouvoir
rémunérer en fait l'intervention de
chaque professionnel que ce soit les
professionnels de ville que ce soit les
professionnels de nos établissements qui
assurent notamment une fonction de
coordination c'est pourquoi nous sommes
très supportifs de pouvoir développer
des financements au parcours en corps
davantage pour les soins de support que
cela ne puisse pas intervenir seulement
en aval de la prise en charge mais dès
le début de la prise en charge pour la
prévention cela était d'ailleurs évoqué
dans la réforme du financement comme une
piste de pouvoir développer des
financements en dehors de la T2A qui
vont être dédiés à la prévention il va
falloir donc pouvoir travailler pour que
cela puisse se concrétiser mais
également développé par exemple
l'hospitalisation à domicile en
cancérologie nous portons ainsi un
projet avec la Fédération la phnéade
pour pouvoir développer un forfait qui
permettrait de favoriser
l'hospitalisation à facile en
cancérologie répondant ainsi également
aux attentes sociétales des patients et
des aidants et puis aux évolutions
scientifiques et techniques qui
permettent de le faire aujourd'hui nous
sommes aussi très supportifs du forfait
en radiothérapie pourquoi parce que cela
nous permettrait de d'avoir des
standards qui correspondent à ce que
font nos collègues aujourd'hui européens
un financement au forfait permet de
réduire le nombre de séances c'est
fondamentales pour la qualité de vie des
patients et pour la pertinence des soins
malheureusement le forfait est
radiothérapie n'était pas dans le
périmètre de la mission sur la réforme
du financement et nous donnerons
convaincus que cela doit être rapidement
mis en œuvre
enfin la quatrième priorité bien sûr
c'est comme ça a été rappelé une réforme
du financement oui mais avec quel
objectif et bien sûr c'est celui de
pouvoir améliorer le parcours des
patients et donc nous sommes sportifs de
pouvoir développer davantage le
financement qui tient qui tiendrait en
compte de l'évaluation de la qualité
de vie réelle faite par les patients
l'épreuve l'épreuves prenant en compte
aussi les délais de prise en charge et
avec des objectifs de réduction de ces
délais sujet qui est si aujourd'hui
importante en termes d'égalité d'accès
pour les patients y compris dans la
prise en charge des cancers et puis de
pouvoir bien sûr aller jusqu'au bout
d'une réforme qui est aussi un impact
sur l'égalité d'accès pour les patients
la prise en charge qui concernent le
financement sujet que vous connaissez
bien des actes de diagnostic moléculaire
pour que l'on puisse enfin permettre de
couvrir l'ensemble des dépenses puisque
rappelons que la aujourd'hui nous permet
de financer que 50% des dépenses en fait
des établissements et donc ne favorise
pas l'accès au diagnostic non
moléculaire qui aujourd'hui guide tous
les traitements tous les traitements en
cancérologie et nous serons très
vigilants bien sûr au sujet des
molécules onéreuses ayant été en 2023
échaudés effectivement sur les sorties
de liste des molécules onéreuses qui
concernaient notamment des médicaments
utiles pour la prise en charge des
cancers je vous remercie merci on va
passer aux questions moi ce qui ce qui
m'agace enfin je vais le dire gentiment
je veux dire on a fait un rapport avec
René Paul Savary sur London c'était en
quelle année 2019 c'est ça ou
2018-2019
18 19
et on entend dire maintenant par le
gouvernement oui peut-être en 2025
bon sur le RIHN parce que c'est celui
des actes ornement clôture pour les les
diagnostics d'accompagnement et qui sont
majeurs pour la prise en charge des
cancers alors qu'on est sur quelque
chose qui est de plus en plus spécifique
de mutations sur lesquelles il faut
faire du des tests de la tumeur avant de
commencer le traitement sauf à faire des
traitements qui ont une utilité relative
c'est pareil ça fait 2018 le rapport
qu'on a fait sur l'accès à l'innovation
c'est 2018 ça n'est toujours pas fait ça
n'est toujours pas fait là bon cette
réforme alors le président Macron avait
mis deux objectifs lors de ses vœux
forment la gouvernance qui était quand
même pas la priorité mais bon dans tact
c'est lui qui décide c'est pas nous donc
mais une réforme de de la gouvernance
qui certes mais depuis les dernières
lois qui permettaient quand même une
souplesse
bon on a mis ça en route avec le
professeur Clarisse qui a fait un très
bon rapport il y a 3 ans qui on demande
de faire un nouveau rapport là on est
sur une réforme de la tarification nous
lorsqu'on a fait la commission d'enquête
sur l'hôpital il y a un an en mars le
rapport a été rendu en mars dernier
Bernard jaumier Président on avait mis
qu'il y avait certes la tarification en
activité incontournable condition que
les critères et les cotations sont assez
simples à faire mais on avait dit aussi
il y a du populationnelle il y a de la
qualité à condition de pas faire une
usine à gaz sur les critères de qualité
aussi mais je pense qu'il y en effet
besoin de critère de qualité et là on se
rend compte avec ce que vous nous dites
qu'en fait il y a encore un périmètre
qui est trop trop court trop trop étroit
de ce qu'on veut faire une réforme donc
on va en faire on va encore faire au
belfss prochains du bricolage des choses
et qui ne rendront pas et qui ne
rendront pas forcément alors c'est
compliqué de remettre tout à plat c'est
bien qu'on avance petit pas par petit
pas mais qu'on avance de façon segmentée
pourquoi pas mais à condition d'avoir
fait un diagnostic très large mais si on
réduit déjà le diagnostic forcément on
aura un traitement partiel et qui ne
correspondra pas aux demandes et ça
franchement on le dira demain au
ministre de la santé que l'on reçoit
mais ça devient lassant quoi ça devient
lassant moi je trouve bon alors Corinne
Imbert qui rapporte la branche maladie
sur ces bonnes paroles merci madame la
Présidente pour en rajouter une le
contact est posé pour en rajouter une
petite couche le ministre ferait mieux
de lire les rapports du SEDAL les
excellents rapports du Sénat plutôt que
de donner des avis favorables sur des
rapports dans le pdfss qui seront soit
pas écrit soit pas lu voilà ça c'est
fait bien en attendant la présente merci
beaucoup de consacrer nos décisions au
planning de la commission des affaires
sociales
sur ce sur ce sujet après avoir consacré
une
séance de la Commission sur la
gouvernance effectivement des de
l'hôpital
un sujet important parce que l'évolution
du du financement
je veux dire du coeur du réacteur quel
champ en médecine chirurgien obstétrique
aujourd'hui financée par la tarification
à l'activité demander depuis maintenant
plusieurs années par les principaux
acteurs de l'hôpital que que vous êtes
un sujet aussi important car c'est l'une
des deux annonces du président de la
République comme celle-là était rappelée
et puis important parce qu'effectivement
les chances de cette réforme ce serait
le tout prochain PLFSS et comme le Vial
de dire la présidente Catherine Deroche
on risque de faire du du bricolage et
c'est quand même un peu dommage alors
j'ai réalisé pour le compte de la
commission il y a il y a 3 semaines à
déplacement en nouvelle-aquitaine je me
suis déplacé dans un CHU dans un centre
hospitalier dans un esprit et dans une
polyclinique privée et puis j'ai
également rencontré l'agence régionale
de santé alors c'est des copains mais
ils ont la voix un peu forte
mais je
excusez-moi excusez-moi
la Fédération
d'hospitalisation privée a évoqué la
situation actuelle j'aurais envie de
demander à chacun des autres acteurs
quelle est la situation sur le premier
semestre 2023 situation financière bien
sûr de vos établissements en sachant que
chacun n'a pas retrouvé l'activité
d'avant pandémie l'activité de 2019 qui
est qui est un peu la référence vous
avez évoqué l'inflation les difficultés
de recrutement juste en quelques mots si
vous pouviez nous donner je vais dire à
l'instant T mais à ce jour la situation
financière de vos établissements
aussi une petite question
concrète sur quid du niveau de la dette
hospitalière alors que que 13 milliards
de reprises ont été votées en 2020 et on
voit bien aujourd'hui et tout est lié la
difficulté pour les établissements et
pas seulement parce qu'on attend une
réforme mais de faire face à des
investissements qui sont pas pensé
depuis plusieurs années qui ont été
chiffrés pour lequel il y a des
mauvaises surprises parce que il y a
l'inflation et donc on a des estimations
qui se revues à la hausse évidemment et
donc cette incapacité presque à mettre
en musique des projets nécessaires et
indispensables pour les établissements
pour en revenir au financement quel
bilan tirez-vous de la garantie de
financement
qui des établissements qui étaient
appliqués de 2020-2022 quel était quel
était son impact pour vos établissements
est-ce que vous avez pu constater des
effets de bord et comment avez-vous
anticipé ou anticipez vous l'impact du
nouveau dispositif de sécurisation
moduler à l'activité pour 2023 puisque
on voit qu'il compensera pas de la même
façon que la garantie de financement qui
a été mobilisée pour les et qui
regardent des rencontres que j'ai eu
évidemment étaient indispensable et
bienvenue pour chacun des établissements
sur la réforme du financement des
établissements de santé donc annoncé par
le président de la République et sur les
chances fixées comment au-delà alors
j'ai bien compris il y avait un
consensus sur la plurianalité très bien
d'abord est-ce que vous avez tous été
consultés par la Mission IGAS
ou par la chef de projet d'adhés au DGOS
est-ce que le moment vous semble
opportun ou pas au regard de ce que
venir de la présence si on voit ça par
le petit bout de la learniaque par
petits morceaux est-ce que ça sera
pertinent ou pas donc est-ce que c'est
le bon moment quel calendrier estimez
vous réalise d'envisager pour cette
réforme est-ce que le PLFSS 2024 vous
paraît le bon le bon outil estimez-vous
que la réforme de la T2A n'est
aujourd'hui pas non plus la priorité
dans ce contexte
et de manière peut-être plus directe
notamment si vous considérez que la
priorité n'est pas là plutôt que de
réformer la T2A à laquelle on fait
porter tous les mots de l'hôpital le
sujet n'est-il pas en réalité celui des
tarifs et ça a été un moment exprimé par
l'un d'entre vous c'est-à-dire d'avoir
une vision tarifaire et du coup des
actes etc ce qui paraît être du bon sens
je reviens sur la commission d'enquête
aussi qui avait été rapportée par
Catherine Deroche qui avait préconisé un
modèle cible qui devait s'appuyer sur
trois piliers l'activité la dotation
populationnelle et la qualité est-ce que
vous avez réfléchi ou pas à ce modèle
souvent prenez par les acteurs
hospitaliers et avez-vous des pistes de
mise en œuvre si j'ose dire facile
simple et efficace
la Commission avait bien dit qu'il
fallait éviter l'usine à gaz que sont
aujourd'hui les nomenclatures complexes
sous la tarification
enfin quel bilan tirez-vous même si ça a
été abordé aussi un petit peu tout à
l'heure des récentes réformes de
financement évidemment je pense SSR SMS
donc la Fédération d'hospitalisation
privée a mis voilà concrètement chiffré
après la troisième version est-ce que
vraiment cette réforme elle doit aboutir
est-ce que si on en est à la troisième
simulation c'est que ça ne tourne pas
que ça ne marche pas et puis enfin vous
avez parlé
de la révision de lambda hospitalier
j'allais dire dans une réforme aussi
importante que celle là est-ce que vous
avez imaginé un Honda hospitalier cible
c'est à dire que vous connaissez la dame
hospitalier tel que voter dans le
dernier père FSS sans dégradés fortement
les contes de la sécurité social
qu'est-ce qui serait pour vous quelque
chose de raisonnable de faisable et
j'allais dire presque vital pour les
établissements ça c'était la question
cerise sur le gâteau très bien
on répond déjà aux questions de la
rapporteur et ensuite sur des collègues
vont intervenir qui commence on refait
normalement allez je veux bien commencer
ça fait beaucoup de questions donc
rafraîchirer ma mémoire si au passage
j'en oublie quelques-unes alors
peut-être déjà un point sur la situation
financière des établissements et et pour
ce qui nous concerne les établissements
publics de santé on est dans une
situation financière extrêmement
préoccupante de sortie de crise si on
peut appeler ça une sortie de crise
parce que force cette constater qu'on
envoie pas le bout puisque après les
vagues épidémiques ou l'hôpital public a
pris
a pris effectivement un rôle de bouclier
sanitaire extrêmement important avec 85
à 86 % des des séjours covid là où on
pour 57% des séjours en situation
d'avant crise et 69% des nuitées donc on
a pris effectivement une part
extrêmement importante dans ces dans ces
vagues épidémiques et c'est également
vrai pour la grippe et la bronchite
parce qu'il y a pas eu que le covid
après on a eu effectivement pendant deux
années de suite
des épidémies de bronchiolite
extrêmement sévères plus précoce
qu'avant on peut plus parler d'épidémie
hivernale maintenant on est
effectivement sur des épidémies
saisonnières et les courbes sont assez
significatives sur ces deux dernières
années avec une violence des des piques
en termes de recours aux urgences de
recours à l'hospitalisation très
important qui nous ont amenés aussi à
des programmer des prises en charge
d'enfants en chirurgie en médecine et
puis la grippe qui a été également
particulièrement violente cette année
qui nous a amené également à
déprogrammer mais assez crises et ses
vagues épidémiques avec une incertitude
encore sur sur l'avenir à succéder
effectivement une tension sur les
recrutements les effectifs qui
existaient avant on avait déjà
effectivement des postes vacants
ressentismes effectivement augmenter
pendant pendant la crise mais avec des
personnels fatigués des personnels aussi
atteints par les les pathologies comme
le covid et la grippe mais qui se sont
fortement accrues avec une tension sur
le capacitaire on a aujourd'hui des
blocs fermés par manque d'ibood on a
aujourd'hui des lits fermés par manque
d'infirmière d'être soignants et puis on
part de toute façon d'une situation de
30% de postes vacants en moyenne de
postes vacants de personnels médicales
titulaires à l'hôpital donc on est
aujourd'hui dans une situation d'effets
ciseaux entre des recettes qui ne sont
pas au rendez-vous du fait de d'une
activité qui ne retrouve pas son niveau
initial et ce de façon durable puisque à
des déprogrammations liées à la crise
sanitaire ont succédé effectivement des
difficultés liées aux personnel aux
tensions sur sur les effectifs donc
aujourd'hui en 2022 on n'a pas retrouvé
un niveau d'activité normal par exemple
sur chirurgie on est à -1% sur
l'ensemble des établissements de santé
mais moins 5% sur l'hôpital public donc
effectivement particulièrement pénalisé
dans cette reprise d'activités y compris
sur l'ambulatoire qui a tout juste
retrouver son niveau
initial d'avant crise en 2022 à
l'hôpital public donc une situation
effectivement particulièrement
particulièrement pénalisante pour pour
l'hôpital public et puis alors même si
effectivement vous l'avez dit il y a des
mécanismes de garantie qui était
absolument indispensables la garantie de
financement nous a sauvé la vie très
clairement dans les hôpitaux publics ça
nous a sauvés la vie ça a été des
milliards d'euros 80% des établissements
et encore une forte proportion y compris
en 2022 donc il était indispensable
d'avoir un dispositif effectivement qui
nous permet alors qu'on souhaitait là
aussi plus ryanuelle nous on avait
proposé un système sur trois ans avec
une dégressivité pour l'instant le
dispositif de sécurisation des recettes
pour l'instant dans la loi prévu que
pour un an et c'est vrai qu'on
s'inquiète déjà pour 2024 puisqu'on sait
que 2023 c'est encore une année atypique
on a démarré par des déprogrammations
liées à la grippe en début d'année donc
on sait que on aura des difficultés en
termes de recettes sachant que on a
également un phénomène qui est lié à la
garantie de financement de
sous-exécution puisque les phénomènes
les dispositifs de garanties de
financement ou de sécurisation des
recettes n'en partent que les effets
tarifs et pas les effets volume donc on
se retrouve en 2022 on a quand même eu
421 millions de sous-exécution côté
établissement exDG public et
établissements privés non lucratif dont
on nous a restitués qu'une partie ce qui
fait que il y a un manque à gagner
effectivement donc on estime aujourd'hui
alors même si on n'a pas les comptes de
résultats définitifs contre l'effet de
l'inflation on est sur des évolutions de
dépenses en 2022 entre 5 et 6% sur le
personnel 9% sur les dépenses
général dont l'énergie en 2023 ça va
être encore plus que cela notamment sur
les dépenses de fonctionnement qu'on
estime de voir évoluer de l'ordre de
19%. donc sur les dépenses hors
personnel on est sur 14% alors c'est
essentiellement l'énergie on a un effet
report dans les hôpitaux publics il y a
un certain nombre d'établissements
publics de santé qui en 2022
bénéficiaient de contrats groupés sur
l'énergie donc avec des effets pris
quand même assez
qui ont été un peu neutralisés en 2022
alors il y a des établissements qui
avaient des contrats isolés qui se sont
pris de plein fouet déjà les
augmentations mais c'était pas le cas
notamment des gros or il va y avoir un
effet report et rattrapage en 2023 qui
est assez là aussi assez violent donc on
estime que l'hypothèse d'un doublement
du déficit hospitalier je dirais
structurel d'avant crise de 500 à 600
millions d'euros donc pour atteindre un
milliard d'euros n'est pas une hypothèse
d'école malheureusement même si nous
n'avons pas les comptes les comptes
financiers à ce jour donc
extrêmement préoccupante et comme vous
l'avez dit c'est évidemment un risque
pour l'investissement parce que dans une
situation d'incertitude et déficit on
investit pas parce que comme on l'a dit
l'investissement il est basé sur une
visibilité plus ryt annuelle
l'investissement le financement de
l'innovation on est sur des cycles longs
et on est sur une prise de risque or on
est sur une gestion de l'âme qui est
annuelle ou infra annuelle qui est basé
sur la réduction totale des risques
c'est normal les financiers et les
comptables leur travail c'est
effectivement de réduire au maximum le
risque sauf que investir dans la santé
investir dans l'innovation c'est
forcément une prise de risque 12 cette
proposition effectivement de gestion
plus réelle avec une réserve plus
annuelle qui permet d'amortir les les
aléas potentiels
sur le
les les
réformes en cours
sur SSR psychiatrie et
urgence alors sur psychiatrie et SFR
pour nous c'était absolument
indispensable d'engager des réformes
tout simplement pour mettre fin à une
inégalité totale de traitement entre les
secteurs puisqu'on avait d'un côté une
enveloppe fermée avec une dotation
globale l'équivalent d'une dotation
globale et de l'autre côté un
financement à l'activité non médicalisée
à la journée qui effectivement était une
enveloppe ouverte et donc avec des taux
d'évolution significativement différents
la Cour des comptes la très bien très
bien documentée pour la psychiatrie on
avait des écarts de taux d'évolution
entre secteur de 1 à 4 donc ça c'est
absolument impossible surtout qu'en
psychiatrie le poids du secteur public
est très fort nous avons 80% de la file
active de psychiatrie qui est accueilli
dans les hôpitaux publics et dans les
secteurs publics sachant que 80% des
prises en charge en psychiatrie se fait
en ambulatoire il y a eu un virage vers
l'ambulatoire commencer par les hôpitaux
au psychiatriques et les secteurs de
psychiatrie publique qui est majeur fort
heureusement
l'hospitalisation n'est plus l'activité
principale en psychiatrie les patients y
compris les patients lourds sont
effectivement suivis essentiellement en
ambulatoire donc pour nous il fallait
effectivement mettre fin et qu'on est
les mêmes règles de financement les
mêmes incitatifs donc pour nous c'était
absolument indispensable alors sur les
usurgences c'est je dirais quelque chose
qui est bien enclenché a priori les
s'écarts fonctionnent de façon plutôt
satisfaisante et comment ça s'emparer de
cette réforme de financement en termes
de levier de structuration de l'offre
donc ça c'est plutôt effectivement
quelque chose d'intéressant sur la
psychiatrie c'est encore trop récent
pour en tirer vraiment ce type
d'enseignement on est encore au début de
la démarche et justement il faut aller
vers cela qu'on puisse se servir de de
cette réforme comme d'un levier sur le
SMS c'est une réforme qu'on appelait de
nos vœux aujourd'hui effectivement on
constate que les simulations ne donnent
pas les résultats attendus par rapport
aux objectifs posés qui étaient
effectivement un objectif là encore de
d'égalité et d'équité de traitement pour
l'instant les hôpitaux publics sont
donnés perdants et de façon assez
sensible de l'ordre de près de 3% de
leurs ressources donc c'est absolument
énorme pour nous l'objectif de la
réforme n'était pas de valoriser
uniquement les soins spécialisés
d'ailleurs nous nous sommes très
majoritairement
investie sur les soins polyvalents
gériatriques avec des patients
extrêmement dépendants manifestement le
modèle ne reconnaît pas cette dépendance
et cette lourdeur liée à la à la
dépendance des patients et donc on est
pour l'instant effectivement défavorisé
donc on appelle une évolution du des
paramètres du modèle ce qui a priori
d'ailleurs
absolument pas exclu parce qu'on nous a
toujours dit que dans les réformes on
appliquait effectivement un modèle en
première instance qu'on pouvait bien
évidemment faire faire évoluer mais pour
l'instant il y a un problème de
compréhension de nos acteurs d'une
réforme dont ils attendaient beaucoup et
notamment une évolution des recettes
plus importantes parce que dans le passé
on a une évolution des recettes qui a
été freinées par une enveloppe fermée et
donc là pour l'instant effectivement il
y a un écart entre les objectifs
attendus et les résultats qu'on constate
mais bon on en est au début de la
démarche donc on ne désespère pas de
faire évoluer le modèle je sais pas si
j'ai balayé
pardon
alors
un minima on est sur plus
un minima on est sur plusieurs milliards
parce que sur l'inflation on est déjà
sur un sous-financement extrêmement
conséquent on a des mesures qui sont
annoncées sur la fonction publique pas
hospitalière en fonction publique dans
son ensemble on est déjà sur une
estimation de 900 millions sur la
fonction publique hospitalière en 2023
et 1 milliard 7 en 2024 et encore dans
le 1 milliard 7 de 2024 je suis pas sûr
qu'il y a l'effet prime qui va démarrer
en 2023 donc je crois que c'est encore
des estimations provisoires et on sera
sur des effets du même ordre puisque
nous ce qui nous inquiète beaucoup c'est
que ce que nous demandions à l'hôpital
public c'était une valorisation des
suggestions les suggestions
hospitalières publics qui sont largement
assumées par l'hôpital public en termes
de permanence des soins en termes
de garde d'astreinte on représente 90%
des crédits de la permanence des soins
on établissement de santé ce sont ces
suggestions et cette lourdeur des
suggestions qui sont la première cause
aujourd'hui de départ au plus que les
niveaux de rémunération et les écarts de
rémunération donc on attendait des
actions il y a déjà des mesures
provisoires qui ont été fort
heureusement mises en oeuvre mais on
attendait une pérennisation de ces
mesures une sécurisation de ces mesures
sur le travail de nuit sur les gardes
sur les astreintes on est effectivement
dans des valorisations du même ordre on
va être dans les deux milliards d'euros
comme ça à grosse à grosse maille et ça
c'est juste la base donc on est
effectivement sur un ondame qui demande
plusieurs milliards d'euros on est déjà
au moins sur 5 milliards d'euros quand
on est bout à bout tout cela sans
compter les sous-valorisations du Ségur
puisque on n'arrive pas à complètement
ou du point d'indice on n'arrive pas
complètement effectivement à couvrir les
charge réelle par rapport au crédit
pourtant très important mais absolument
pas en cause le soutien des pouvoirs
publics mais on est effectivement
dans une dans une évolution de l'ONDAM
qui est très forte à minimale juste pour
voilà avoir la base de l'évolution c'est
pour cela qu'on appelle aussi de nos
vœux et la réforme du financement pour
être l'occasion de mettre la pertinence
des soins la prévention au cœur de la
rénovation du financement du système de
santé pour redéger des marges de
manœuvre
oui sur la prévention moi je dis
toujours la prévention et à moyen terme
un des meilleurs sur lesquels sur
lesquels on aura un retour d'économie
bien évidemment et qui pourra permettre
de financer général c'est évident on le
voit notamment cancérologie quand on
voit le nombre de cancers qui mais dans
d'autres pathologies aussi et si on
néglige la prévention on accumule du
soin de dernier recours ou de
pathologies plus graves et juste
peut-être quelques mots sur la réforme
du financement et la mission et gaswy
nous avons été auditionnés à plusieurs
reprises on a pu contribuer à faire des
contributions écrites on espère
d'ailleurs être associé parce qu'il y a
encore des travaux notamment de
simulation et enfin un outil de
simulation alors en 2024 il y aura rien
à quasiment rien il y aura effectivement
quelques lignes ou quelques articles
dans le plfs 2024 c'est plutôt une
application pour 2025 voire 2026 qui
semble effectivement plus réalistes qui
nous est annoncé ce qui nous embête
juste comme l'a dit je crois que c'est
Sophie beau-père qui qui l'a dit sur le
protocole le plus granulité on pense
qu'on peut faire les choses avant parce
qu'on nous dit il y a pas de visibilité
sur 2024 Laura ton plus en 2025 on peut
en douter donc il y a un moment je pense
qu'il faut s'engager et prendre des
risques collectivement ensemble sur ce
qu'on est des gens responsables on peut
signer on la démontré à travers le
premier et protocole sauf qu'on a
tendance il y a quand même des plans
d'économiques qui ne disent pas leur nom
qui sont pas affichés comme tel qui se
prennent et ce sont des
désolé pour l'expression mais un peu
quand même des décisions à
l'emporte-pièce et à la petite semaine
sans réflexion de long terme sans
concertation des acteurs tout à l'heure
on évoquait la liste en Suisse on a
également le même la même problématique
sur les dispositifs médicaux où on a
radié de la liste en Suisse sans aucune
concertation préalable ce qu'on a eu une
réunion le 16 décembre en 2022 donc une
réunion en décembre pour une application
d'une décision au 1er mars on peut pas
tellement appeler ça une concertation ni
même une information minimale puisque
c'était vraiment en Extrême Limite et on
a
dispositif de type de dispositifs qui
ont été radiés sans réintégration dans
les tarifs donc ça c'est une nouvelle
doctrine donc ça correspond à un des
remboursements sur les guides FFR qui
permettent effectivement de poser un
diagnostic sur la nécessité de faire un
acte en suite plus important alors en
termes de pertinence si on arrête de
faire cela et les industriels nous ont
dit dans la semaine
que il constatait déjà une baisse de du
recours au guide SFR et donc ça va
vouloir dire des examens
inutiles non pertinents plus nombreux à
l'avenir si on n'a plus effectivement
ces actes de diagnostic et sur la
trompectomie mécanique qui est radié
effectivement de la liste en Suisse sans
compensation dans les tarifs qui a
montré toute son efficacité dans le
traitement des AVC dans la réduction des
décès liés aux AVC dans la réduction du
handicap des séquelles liés aux AVC les
maladies cardiovasculaires sont une des
premières causes de décès et de handicap
en France notamment chez la femme c'est
la première cause de de dessèche et la
femme chez l'homme c'est encore le
cancer parce que c'est messieurs ont
encore ou les générations concernées
vont encore des comportements à risque
plus importants que chez les dames a
priori il paraît que ça va se
malheureusement malheureusement ça va
s'égaliser ce qui est pas forcément une
bonne nouvelle d'ailleurs mais pour
l'instant les maladies cardiovasculaires
c'est la première cause de décès chez la
femme la deuxième crochet l'homme c'est
voilà c'est et là c'est
l'incompréhension totale pour les
communautés hospitalières parce que des
remboursés des techniques qui ont montré
toute leur efficacité qui ne sont pas
généralisées qui ne sont pas arrivés à
maturité donc là nous on demande dans
les mécanismes de radiation de la liste
en Suisse que ça soit pas uniquement des
mécanismes comptables économiques à
partir du moment on est en dessous de
30% du coût des GHS on sort mais sur les
dispositifs innovants il faut qu'on ait
un cliquet de sauvegarde une clause de
sauvegarde sur des dispositifs innovants
non arrivés à maturité et bien ça ce
n'est pas radié de la liste en Suisse
tant qu'on n'a pas effectivement
généralisé la technique ça va se
reproduire sur 2024 on nous annonce déjà
toujours sur les maladies
cardiovasculaires des sorties de liste
de dispositif là aussi qui ont montré
toute leur efficacité donc le problème
c'est que tant qu'on ne n'engage pas ses
chantiers de longue haleine des
décisions se prennent effectivement qui
sont extrêmement délétères alors on
comprend bien qu'il y ait des économies
à faire au vu de la situation des
finances publiques mais ce type
d'économie là peut même être
contre-productive et au final aboutir à
moins de pertinence et plus de dépenses
très bien alors je crois que madame a un
impératif donc on va faire la FHP et
ensuite on viendra la FEA pour unique
cancer sauf si vous même vous avez des
impératifs horaires oui merci et puis on
vous prie de nous excuser parce
qu'effectivement on a un train et on va
être obligé de vous quitter dans 5
minutes alors pour répondre à ces
rapidement à l'ensemble des questions
donc d'abord dire sur la garantie de
financement pour repartir un peu dans le
dans les chaudements historiques ça a
été quand même quelque chose qui était
tout à fait Cécile l'a dit un salutaire
et heureusement que ce dispositif a été
mis en place pour accompagner nos
établissements parce que sinon ça serait
pas sorti néanmoins on n'a pas tous les
chiffres pour 2022 puisque on a demandé
nous au titre de la FHP donc d'avoir les
chiffres de d'activité de mise en place
de la garantie de financement et
finalement les chiffres qui
objectifaient la sous-exécution dont
nous avons été exclues et nous n'avons
pas eu la réponse nous avons saisi la
CADA qui nous a qui a demandé à ce que
cette réponse ne soit à fournie et à ce
jour on a un fichier absolument
inexploitable et donc un manque de
transparence sur les conditions
d'exécution de l'ONDAM ce qui est très
embêtant mais on a un comité économique
la semaine prochaine on espère qu'on
aura des informations complémentaires
alors vous dire que les établissements
privés donc pour 2020 en MCO avait pour
61% d'entre eux bénéficier de la
garantie de financement en 2021 c'était
56% et 80% pour le secteur MC au public
donc on y a moins recours que dans le
public et pour 2022 comme vous l'avez
compris nous n'avons pas les chiffres
sur le dispositif qui est mis en place
de sécurisation moduler à l'activité
pour 2023 c'est un dispositif
transitoire qui va qui va appuyer les
établissements qui pourraient être en
difficulté néanmoins dire que on a un
petit souci sur les référentiels qui
sont pris puisque les référentiels qui
sont pris pour calculer ces garanties de
financement sont toujours ceux de 2019
tous s'est arrêté 2019 c'est à dire que
quand on quand on a des discussions sur
des mesures de financement RH bah on
nous donne la SAE 2019 quand on a des
financements de base le socle c'est
toujours 2019 donc tout s'est arrêté en
2019 donc ça ça pose un problème sans
nul doute et aujourd'hui donc sur les
résultats alors on est en cours de
consolidation d'un document qu'on pourra
vous adresser
dans dans alors peut-être peut-être que
ce document sera plutôt dans une
quinzaine de jours mais c'est un
document c'est une étude qui pourra qui
pourra vous intéresser qui dresse un
bilan de la situation économique de nos
établissements à partir d'un panel qui
représente plus de 40% de nos de nos
établissements ce que l'on peut en dire
c'est que s'il y avait pas eu les
recettes annexes vous savez qui qui sont
donc financés par les assureurs
complémentaires donc la MC et s'il y
avait pas eu la garantie de financement
2022 80% de nos établissements seraient
déficitaires donc en fait on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui déjà de toute façon
systémique et un sous-financement par
l'assurance maladie du soin mais en plus
c'est vrai que ce dispositif a permis un
certain nombre d'établissement d'être à
l'équilibre cependant on a 30 %
établissement déficitaire et le niveau
de résultats net des établissements MCO
et illimité à 1%, ce qui finalement ça
veut dire aucune marge de manœuvre et
c'est la raison pour laquelle tout à
l'heure je me permettais d'insister sur
le nécessaire financement des mesures
ressources humaines des revalorisations
salariales dans le public comme dans le
privé parce que on dispositif on ne
dispose absolument pas des marges et en
plus on a un contexte
d'inflation qui était les et puis un peu
ce socle finalement avec toutes les
réformes qui s'ajoutent qui se cumulent
qui sont pas finies et qui qui qui
un climat d'incertitude qui fait que on
est en train de bloquer complètement
l'investissement voir décourager un
certain nombre d'investisseurs vous
demandiez tout à l'heure finalement quel
serait pour nous la priorité il y a deux
priorités nous semble-t-il pour remettre
un peu de stabilité dans un socle et
dans un paysage qui est tout à fait
instable premièrement donc la priorité
de définir quelques objectifs
stratégiques prioritaires et de
travailler à la plurianité sur quelques
objectifs pas de sang moins de 10 voilà
donc il y a moins de 10 et remettre
aussi les équipes avec des perspectives
et des perspectives qui soient visibles
donc en nombre réduits donc ça c'est une
première priorité la deuxième priorité
et ça fait longtemps que nous
l'exprimons au niveau de la FHP c'est un
grand plan attractivité Emploi Formation
santé et ça c'est pas que pour le
sanitaire c'est aussi pour le
Médico-Social pour la ville c'est
quelque chose qui est absolument majeurs
on sait que aujourd'hui les les jeunes
générations un rapport au travail qui a
évolué il faut le travailler il faut le
prendre en compte et il faut absolument
remettre en perspective un dispositif de
formation qui qui fonctionne mieux nous
établissements de santé et pour l'avoir
beaucoup travaillé avec nos collègues
c'est une position que nous partageons
nous sommes prêts à nous investir sur
les stages sur l'apprentissage sur le
remakedage des formations sur
l'évolution des formations sur la
participation à l'appareil de formation
on est prêt à prendre et à travailler
sur ces sujets dans le cadre d'ailleurs
du protocole pluriel mais pour autant il
faut qu'il y ait une décision qui soit
qui soit prise
c'est vrai que il faut peut-être éviter
les usines à gaz techno donc remettre
des mots simples sur des objectifs
simples donc vous avez dit un
financement à la qualité nous partageons
tout à fait tout à fait cet objectif et
avec de la visibilité puisque juste pour
vous donner et peut-être vous faire
sourire même si c'est un peu triste les
modalités de de financement
IFAC 2022 ont été connus le 30 décembre
2022 c'est pas comme ça qu'on peut
piloter une politique qualité et piloter
le futur enfin pour parler en quelques
mots de la du SMR en fait qui qui
illustre finalement ce que ce que ne
doit pas être nous on est pour la
réforme du financement SMR donc c'est
pas le fond qui est en qui est en cause
c'est la façon dont les choses se sont
organisées et les risques du coup qu'on
pourrait voir sur une extension majeure
à toutes les activités sans avoir pris
retour d'expérience du SMS
c'est vrai que les les financements sont
basés sur une moyenisation donc ça c'est
pas un objectif de santé publique nous
on pense que une réforme doit être
accompagnée d'une augmentation des
financements et là on demande que le
système de facturation est financement
actuel soit maintenu pour 2024 comme les
derniers six mois 2023 afin d'éviter de
d'accroître les difficultés enfin sur
l'évolution de la dame juste dire pour
ajouter aux propos de Cécile chevance
que nous partageons totalement on avait
on pourra aussi vous remettre ce
document mais je pense que vous l'avez
déjà eu en début d'année mais néanmoins
il est toujours d'actualité on a
retravaillé sur ces sujets là on estime
que sur 2022 2023 sur la partie
inflation or RH il manquait 4,3
milliards d'euros pour l'ensemble de nos
établissements donc en fait il y a
beaucoup d'effets qui se cumulent et les
chiffres qui ont été cités par la par la
FHF donc nous on avait un effet à chaque
était beaucoup plus important sur 2000
sur 2022 et sur 2023 puisque on n'avait
pas cette couverture pour la plupart de
nos établissements de l'énergie donc on
n'a pas eu cet effet report et donc on a
un effet d'au moins 12% sur les achats
donc qui est extrêmement important sa
raison pour laquelle entre ces effets
sur les charges et sur les achats plus
les loyers etc etc parce que tout ça se
rajoute bien entendu et sur les
ressources humaines avec les mesures qui
sont juste de revalorisation et de
défense des salaires parce qu'on a des
salaires qui sont pas très élevés quand
même dans la dans les dans les
établissements de santé donc il faut il
faut accompagner nos salariés pour
qu'ils puissent prendre en charge le
coût de l'inflation et et avoir une
situation décente et donc le le taux
auquel on va arriver ça forcément au
dessus de 6% donc on travaille sur cette
question là en lien avec le ministère de
présenter mais on rejoint les propos de
Cécile chevance l'augmentation de la
dame pour 2024 sera très significative
et il faut travailler aussi bien sûr on
la rejoint sur la pénibilité spécifique
des métiers et donc avoir un plan sur la
tractivité qui prennent en compte aussi
des questions sur la qualité de vie au
travail sur les suggestions spécifiques
à l'hôpital et pas simplement de dire
voilà on va remettre de l'argent au
Ségur on a peut-être trop économisé
cette question de travailler un peu sur
le fond des choses je vous remercie et
puis je vous prie vraiment de nous
excuser non mais vous enverrez la
contribution qui qui continue l'a fait y
aller pour la suite merci beaucoup sur
la d'abord sur la situation financière
vous dire que elle est en forte
dégradation depuis
plusieurs plusieurs mois alors lié à
plusieurs phénomènes alors l'inflation
j'y reviens pas exogène un phénomène de
changement de 15 mix d'activités avec
une part de l'ambulatoire qui progresse
de manière significative on peut que
s'en réjouir mais une activité en volume
de séjour qui est important de plus 5 %
sur 2022 mais on valorisation qui n'est
que de que de 1% ce qui pose des
problèmes importants de déséquilibre de
nos établissements qui ne sont pas pour
ce qui nous concerne immortel on a des
fonds propres on a des on a des des vies
d'entreprises ou d'associations et des
sujets de pérennité à terme de nos
établissements j'ajoute un deuxième
effet c'est l'effet attractivité et je
souhaiterais redire
qu'on a un problème d'équité de
financement notamment sur des missions
identiques et je pense notamment au
financement des mesures Braun sur les
urgences et services en tension dont le
bénéficie pas des établissements du
privé solidaire combien même ils
assurent des missions de service public
y compris en période estivale dans les
villes de Bordeaux par exemple de
Strasbourg de Paris puisqu'on nous
demande de venir on appuie des hôpitaux
publics pour assurer l'accueil des
urgences notamment de nuit où l'accueil
des urgences tout court et nous avons
une vraie difficulté puisque on ne peut
pas servir aux salariés de la ferme les
mêmes
avantages on va dire que les les
fonctionnaires du de l'hôpital public
notamment sur ces services ce qui crée
une vraie difficulté de recrutement et
une impossibilité pour l'établissements
qui ont la capacité juridique de mettre
en œuvre ces mesures mais n'en n'ont pas
la capacité financière puisque c'est
inatteignable pour la Catho de Lille par
exemple les mesures c'est un million
800.000 euros et c'est pas possible de
prendre ça sur sur fond propre alors on
a été accompagné par la garantie de
financement dont on considère qu'elle
permet dans son dispositif 2023 de lycée
la sortie de cette même garantie donc
heureusement encore une fois que c'est
une garantie était là puisque la très
grande majorité de nos établissements
étaient ont été bénéficiaires de cette
guerre de cette garantie et le reste
encore encore cette année pour les
raisons que j'indiquais en termes de
changement de profil d'activité au
profit de l'ambulatoire sur le sujet des
réformes psy SMR nous aussi nous
soutenons l'esprit de la réforme nous
sommes attentifs aux dotations
populationnelle qui peuvent être
construites avec les ARS et nous nous
demandons à cette occasion que des
règles claires soient établies sur la
méthodologie de construction de ces de
ces de ces objectifs et sur pour faire
vite et sur le
le sujet de la réforme alors on est
assez circonspect sur une mise en oeuvre
de la réforme au 1er janvier 2024 on
aura jamais été aussi vite pourquoi pas
on verra on n'est pas sûr qu'on arrive à
quoi que ce soit il y a un vrai sujet
mais si vous additionnez le ministre il
vous répondra peut-être qui est quel est
le 15 mix de la réforme c'est à dire
qu'elle part on met sur la T2A qu'elle
part on met sur l'émission qu'elle part
on met sur les objectifs de santé
publique c'était pas à la mission
d'expert de définir c'est c'est par mais
on sait qu'il y a 50 milliards d'un côté
15 milliards de l'autre est-ce que on
réduit de moitié la T2A ou est-ce qu'on
enlève un milliard de deux as qui sera
absolument pas le même effet en terme de
en termes de réforme et c'est le sujet
qui nous préoccupe et se rejoint le
sujet de la modélisation et des
simulations qui peuvent être qui peuvent
être faites et sur la sur la méthode on
sera vraiment très attentif à la
modalités de mise en œuvre évidemment de
cette réforme enfin sur le long terme
hospitalier
pas grand chose à ajouter des effets
exogènes très forts des mesures
salariales qui s'accumulent et qui donc
viennent alourdir les les les coûts de
fonctionnement de nos établissements on
serait entre 4 et 5% aujourd'hui de
coûts automatiques à répercuter mais
encore une fois il faut le il faut le il
faut le reconstruire le reconstruire
ensemble voilà en quelques mots ce que
je pouvais dire pour la pour notre
fédération
Sophie beaupère merci mon propos vont
rejoindre ceux de mes collègues alors
sous le bilan de la garantie de
financement il y a cette centre sur 18
qui ont bénéficié de la garantie de
financement
il y a des effets de bord pour répondre
à la question puisque notamment ce qui a
été très mal vécu par les centres vous
savez qu'ils ont assuré l'accueil en
plus des patients qui pouvaient pas
forcément être pris en charge dans
d'autres structure il n'y a pas eu à la
fin de l'année de dégel total et il y a
eu qu'un dégel partiel qui a donc
pénalisé financièrement les centres
alors même effectivement qu'il y a une
progression d'activité des cancers hier
est paru le panorama un cas santé
publique France qui montrait un
doublement des des cas de cancer en 30
ans donc évidemment la progression
d'activité et la difficulté de la tâche
sont bien sûr très présents dans nos
établissements et dans les autres qui
effectivement prennent en charge de
cancer
financièrement il y a c'est assez inédit
d'ailleurs il y a 7 centres sur 18 qui
sont déficitaires à la fin de l'année
voilà pour la réalité financière
notamment
en même temps il y a une progression
d'activité au premier quadrimestre 2023
il y a plus 7 % d'activités dans nos
établissements mais comme j'ai dit une
tension inédite pourquoi comme la
rappeler Charles pour les sujets aussi
de d'équité de traitement avec l'hôpital
public les mesures bonnes en sont un
exemple aujourd'hui du coup on a grosse
difficulté pour le personnel de nuit à
demeurer être actif puisque c'est très
mal vécu par nos professionnels qui
assurent la prise en charge des cancers
la continuité des soins de ne pas
bénéficier de ces mesures et cela est
difficile aujourd'hui 6 de nos
établissements bénéficient du dispositif
de sécurisation
existant à noter que dans ces six
établissements il y a les plus gros
centres de lutte contre le cancer
notamment Gustave aussi curry Paoli
Calmette à Marseille pourquoi parce
qu'il y a une contraction finalement des
ressources humaines une difficulté à
rester attractif et du coup une charge
qui s'accroît pour ceux qui restent et
une difficulté donc à pouvoir maintenir
des lits ouverts alors même que
l'activité est au rendez-vous
sur les la réforme de la T2A c'est vrai
que nous avions appelé de nos vœux qui
est au préalable un bilan d'avantage
partagé à la fois de la T2A et de la
garantie de financement parce qu'il y a
eu un rapport idéal sur la garantie de
financement mais nous l'avons pas
partagé
entre fédérations avec le ministère et
c'est sûr que c'est sans doute opportun
de partager un bilan avant de de se
lancer dans une réforme et pour
rejoindre mes collègues pour nous il
faut que quelques priorités c'est
l'équité traitement pour les structures
exerçantes des missions de service
public c'est le financement des
investissements qui nous préoccupe
énormément en tant que centre
d'expertise et de rec pourquoi parce que
il faut pouvoir avoir une stratégie et
parce que dans le cadre du Ségur les
sans doute contre le cancer ont
bénéficié peu du Ségur investissement
ils ont reçu rappelons le 0,4% des
crédits alors que si on prend juste
l'activité MCO qui le réalise 2,5 % du
coup il y a une difficulté aujourd'hui
pour les établissements à pouvoir
renouveler leur parc bien sûr de
machines si important en cancérologie
d'adapter aussi leur bâtiment à la
transition énergétique et puis les
orientations qui nous paraissent
majeures au-delà donc de financement des
investissements qui ne peut avoir que
une une vision plus réelle c'est bien
sûr le financement de la prévention nous
pensons que nous pouvons développer des
parcours qui permettront d'assurer une
prévention efficace ce qui est développé
par Gustave Roussy le programme
interception prévention à destination
des personnes à haut risque de cancer en
est un exemple venons de déposer un
article 51 qui permettrait de
généraliser cette ce programme à
l'ensemble des centres de luttes contre
le cancer sur le territoire et espérons
que cela pourrait être un exemple de ce
qui pourrait être fait en matière de
financement d'appréhension efficace et
pouvant prouver qu'on peut avoir des
résultats notamment en termes de non
hospitalisation prise en charge le plus
tôt possible
des cas de concert et enfin
le développement du financement à la
qualité qui est un autre sens doit
passer par des indicateurs qualité sans
doute pas aussi macro qu'aujourd'hui
dans le cadre de l'IFAC mais par
pathologie et notamment c'est
intéressant au délai de prise en charge
et permettant donc de d'améliorer la
coordination des acteurs pour répondre à
la question concernant l'ONDA mais
effectivement nous sommes touchés comme
les autres par l'inflation plus 15%
concernant les dépenses de titre 3
d'énergie
à minima entre 2022 et 2023 et donc
l'ONDAM nous paraît au moins de voir
être à plus simple ou 6 %
alors il y a trois collègues qui ont des
questions moins vous avez parlé beaucoup
de formation des personnels est-ce que
vous êtes associé le François Braun a
lancé l'autre jour avec la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur je crois
[Musique]
les travaux sur le métier d'infirmier
est-ce que les fédérations étaient
associées
non
ce serait bien qu'à un moment vous y
soyez quand même
on avait parlé à un moment quand on
avait fait notre rapport Catherine
dandamme régionale et savait pas été
tellement bien accepté par vos
différentes quand vous parlez de
prévention et de travail en concertation
avec la somme des acteurs pas seulement
ceux qui font de l'hébergement mais
également en soins de ville serait
logique on est dans un onderme régional
territorialisé et qui soit pas séparés
en dameville et
hôpitaux mais un Honda global
territorial qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
sur ce après et rentrons dans un cadre
plus réel cela me paraît d'une
redoutable evilion ce qu'il faut faire
annuel pour donner une visibilité est-ce
que votre point de vue a changé par
rapport à ces années-là
Alain Milan et Florence Sassard
merci président merci aux fédérations
pour les explications qu'elles nous ont
donné moi je voulais juste vous parler
de charges sociales et de charges
fiscale d'assujettissement à la TVA et
de taxes sur les salaires et vous
demander votre avis sur une
harmonisation des charges sociales et
fiscales
merci beaucoup pour vos contributions
d'abord je vais commencer par un
témoignage qui peut être
intéressant au point de vue école de
formation j'ai visité
récemment à Bordeaux l'école de
formation de de la polyclinique Bordeaux
Nord qui qui forme qui formait au départ
des aides-soignants ces aides-soignants
le recrutement est relativement facile
parce qu'ils arrivent dans un
établissement où ils savent qu'ils
trouveront des débouchés ces
aides-soignants très rapidement leur
propose de devenir par formation interne
et apprentissage infirmiers d'infirmiers
on leur propose également de venir cadre
ils peuvent pas devenir directeur
d'hôpital mais enfin il y a une il y a
un vrai ascenseur social dans ce dans ce
système est-ce que c'est pas ce type de
système de formation interne qui va
falloir privilégier plutôt que des
écoles d'infirmières à recrutement
deuxièmement dans ce pays depuis plus de
30 ans on met systématiquement le paquet
sur les urgences parce que les urgences
c'est là que finalement arrive tous ceux
qui n'ont pas été soignés en amont non
seulement ceux qui trouvent pas de
médecin mais ceux qui n'ont qui arrive
là parce que parce qu'il y a un retard
de prise en charge parce qu'il y a un
échec de prise en charge en particulier
en cancérologie qu'est-ce qu'un malade
du cancer fait dans un service d'urgence
alors qu'il pourrait être pris en charge
dans un dans un établissement approprié
cette embolisation des urgences par des
maladies chroniques est-ce qu'il
faudrait pas se poser la question de
financer suffisamment le
les services où on soigne vraiment ou on
prévient vraiment
plutôt que la fin de chaîne alors est-ce
que je sais bien que le ministre de la
Santé est urgentiste mais est-ce qu'il
faut pas quand même maintenant
être efficace sur les sur le sur la
prise en charge d'Amont
je vais m'arrêter là
Michel Meunier et puis un dimanche
beau-père unique cancer parce que j'ai
dû être distraite mais quand vous avez
parlé de financement parcours
du patient vous allez faire un
rapprochement entre le forfait en
radiothérapie et la meilleure prise en
charge j'ai pas compris comment ça
pouvait être possible donc j'aimerais
bien que vous preniez le temps merci
comment sauf si vous commencez à ce
moment là pour
sur l'ONDAM régional c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs ça a été
souligné par la Mission on a quand même
un enjeu notre fédération de
transparence par exemple des firs des
financements qui sont répartis au niveau
régional on n'a pas toujours le retour
d'ailleurs même transparent de comment
c'est finançants sont attribués donc un
nom d'âme régional nécessiterait d'abord
déjà d'avoir des garanties d'une d'une
grande transparence et de règles claires
de répartition entre établissement quel
que soit leur statut et puis pour la
prise en charge des cancers ça c'est une
conviction il faut une politique
nationale notamment pour gommer les
inégalités d'accès et par exemple un
programme de prévention tel que je le
j'en prenais l'exemple à notre sens il
doit être déployé au niveau national
pour pouvoir donner la même chance à
chacun bien sûr avec des adaptations
régionales correspondant à la réalité de
terrain puisque rappelons que ce type de
programme nécessite la coordination
entre les établissements et les médecins
générales par exemple encore faut-il
avoir tout simplement des médecins
généralistes
et des médecins généralistes qui est un
minimum de temps à pouvoir y consacrer
sur la harmonisation des charges
sociales et fiscales nous ne pouvons
être que favorables puisque nos charges
aujourd'hui sont supérieures à celle de
l'hôpital public et c'est bien sûr un
des sujets concernant la formation
interne oui absolument c'est ce que nous
appelons nos vœux les fédérations
longtemps ça n'a pas été forcément
possible puisque quand on quand on
payait l'apprentissage d'une
aide-soignante elle ne pouvait pas faire
son stage après d'infirmière dans notre
établissement devait être envoyé
ailleurs donc ça c'est les dispositifs
de formation professionnelle qui sont
pas adaptées à la santé qui ont été un
verrou mais c'est une conviction parce
que cela répond plus à une attente
sociétale les professionnels ont besoin
de se projeter d'avoir des perspectives
donc oui absolument ils nous y sommes
pleinement favorables concernant
l'obligation des urgences nous vous
rejoignons pleinement il y a le sujet de
la il y a le sujet de la permanence des
soins mais il y a aussi le sujet dans
les pathologies chroniques et en
cosmologie en particulier de la
continuité des soins et ça ne va qu'à
croître avec le vieillissement de la
population l'augmentation des cas de
cancers comme j'ai évoqué le
développement de l'ambulatoire on doit
se pencher sur ce sujet Comment assurer
la continuité des soins et c'est
certainement pas dans un service
d'urgence généraliste que cela est la
meilleure place pour le faire et c'est
bien une de nos préoccupations majeure
aujourd'hui enfin pour le forfait
radiothérapie pour pour rentrer plus
dans les explications aujourd'hui le
paiement à la séance puisqu'il y a un
paiement à la séance en radiothérapie
nous permet pas d'optimiser le nombre de
séances qui est idéal pour les patientes
les nouvelles techniques et notamment ce
qui peut fractionnement permet
aujourd'hui de faire on a les moyens
techniques de faire un nombre plus
restreint de séances donc avec moins
d'effets secondaires pour les patientes
mais permettant d'atteindre les mêmes
résultats en termes de soins
plusieurs pays européens je pense à la
Hollande enfin la majorité des pays
d'ailleurs ont instauré un financement
au forfait de la radiothérapie en disant
on paye un forfait pour un nombre de
séances donnés limité et cela permet
donc d'optimiser le nombre de séances et
de pousser les acteurs à avoir
une une prise en charge qui soit la plus
plus efficace possible pour les patients
c'est pour ça que nous appelons de nos
vœux ce paiement au forfait je sais pas
si j'ai été
rempli c'est actuellement il y a des le
traitement classique s'étendre séance
par semaine pendant 30 semaines et
maintenant on sait qu'on peut pour avoir
les mêmes résultats avoir un nombre de
séances plus limité ce qui est
intéressant d'abord pour le patient qui
évite les déplacements parce que tout le
monde n'a pas un service de
radiothérapie moi j'en ai dans mon
département où ils vont à Nantes faire
leur séance tous les jours donc plus les
frais déplacement donc ça optimiste ça
optimise aussi l'usage de la machine et
ce nous permet de faire plus de patients
mais le financement actuel n'est pas
favorable à ce type de de modification
de la radiothérapie et c'est ce que
demande les établissements et il me
semble il faut absolument qu'on y aille
parce que le financement est moins
intéressant donc de fait c'est ça je
vais pas perdre c'est ça
le financement au forfait permet
d'optimiser et d'inciter les tous les
acteurs de la radiothérapie à avoir les
machines innovantes qui permettent de
limiter le nombre de séances
l'intérêt des patients un bocaux bien
évidemment l'intérêt des patients c'est
parce que
plusieurs semaines à cinq jours par
semaine c'est lourd parfois donc quand
on peut réduire réduire et je comprends
mieux mais je trouve qu'aujourd'hui le
système est aberrant quand même du point
de vue de l'intérêt du patient
c'est pour ça que nous demandons une
évolution
alors qui
madame sevance
alors sur le long terme régional alors
on a un souci à la fois de d'équité sur
l'ensemble du territoire pour
effectivement qu'on n'est pas des
régions qui qui décrochent alors même si
on constate qu'effectivement l'accès aux
soins il est pas égal partout dans les
faits même si on a au plan réglementaire
effectivement et législatif une une un
principe juridique d'accès aux soins
c'est vrai que la réalité n'est pas
n'est pas tout à fait celle-là les
réformes du financement avec une part de
dotation populationnelle devait répondre
justement à cet objectif de réduction
des inégalités c'était bien tout
l'objectif de la dotation
populationnelle son principal intérêt
d'ailleurs était là donc ça c'est
effectivement un objectif de de
rattrapage
les régions dites
je sais pas si on peut parler sur
dotation de surfinancement compte tenu
du déficit voilà mais en tout cas
considérer comme bien financer et volant
moins vite dans leur dotation
populationnelle que les régions
effectivement sous financées avec
effectivement un phénomène de rattrapage
et c'est vrai quand on regarde par
exemple sur le SMS on a eu des études
par la mission des os très claires ou on
voit qu'on a un décalage entre l'offre
et la demande et les besoins de santé on
n'a pas une corrélation effectivement
complète selon les régions et donc
effectivement une nécessité d'équilibrer
alors pas forcément uniquement entre
région ailleurs mais au sein des régions
aussi parce qu'on a des régions
tellement grandes aujourd'hui qu'on a
des situations quand même assez
différentes d'un territoire à l'autre
donc c'est ces principes en tout cas
dans dans l'intention et dans l'objectif
la dotation populationnelle pour un
certain nombre d'activités nous semblait
justement répondre à cette à cet
objectif
sur les règles différentes en termes de
fiscalité aujourd'hui nous notre souci
l'essentiellement sur le secteur
médico-social avec effectivement des
différencies très importants avec le
secteur public qui ne bénéficie pas
alors en plus une décision qu'on ne peut
plus effectivement être assujetti à la
TVA maintenant alors qu'un certain
nombre de d'EHPAD public c'était engagé
dans cette démarche avec une demande en
plus de récupération y compris sur
l'historique enfin qui met les EHPAD
public dans une situation extrêmement
compliquée sachant qu'aujourd'hui je
crois que Charles geprat l'a évoqué tout
à l'heure on n'a pas dichotomie on
fonctionne souvent en silo entre
sanitaire et médico-social ça fonctionne
ensemble et aujourd'hui sur les centres
hospitaliers 60% des difficultés
financières et du déficit des centres
hospitaliers est lié effectivement au
secteur médico-social où on a
effectivement à la fois des
sous-occupations en termes de d'activité
une augmentation des charges et de
l'inflation qui n'est absolument pas
pris en charge et on a une situation
extrêmement préoccupante au plan voilà
exactement sur la formation oui tout à
fait d'accord avec vous il faut
privilégier effectivement les évolutions
de carrière sur le long terme et
notamment les deuxième partie de
carrière notamment pour les médecins
avec effectivement des perspectives de
deuxième partie de carrière de fin de
carrière et oui c'est vrai qu'on a un
ascenseur social et une promotion
interne d'ailleurs les promotions
professionnelles c'est un dispositif qui
marche extrêmement bien à l'hôpital
public et qu'il faut bien évidemment
promouvoir et tout à fait d'accord avec
vous sur le fait que il faut éviter
l'arrivée des pathologies chroniques en
situation particulièrement aigrue aigu
dans un état grave on a on a le problème
sur le diabète l'insuffisance cardiaque
voilà on peut faire la liste à l'envie
c'est d'ailleurs tout l'objectif de la
démarche de responsabilité
populationnelle que la FHF pilote avec 5
territoires pionniers dans le cadre d'un
article 51
IPE c'est une un appel à manifestation
d'intérêt donc ça concerne cinq
territoires donc une population
importante diabète de type 2
insuffisance cardiaque c'est à la fois
ça concerne les personnes déjà malades
mais également les personnes qui
présentent un risque de développer la
pathologie donc il y a aussi une
démarche d'aller vers une démarche de
prévention donc l'idée c'est bien alors
ça concerne tous les professionnels de
santé de tous statut les établissements
publics mais aussi les établissements
privés le créatif ou non mais aussi les
professionnels libéraux parce que les
pathologies chroniques sont évidemment
prises en charge aussi et avant tout et
heureusement par le premier le premier
recours et pas uniquement l'hôpital fort
heureusement pour pour les personnes
concernées donc l'idée c'est bien
effectivement de réduire l'entrée dans
la maladie ou de retarder entrer dans la
maladie et ensuite effectivement une
fois la maladie installée est réduire et
retarder l'aggravation effectivement des
différents stades de la maladie et
surtout réduire le nombre de passages
aux urgences en situation
dégradé en situation d'urgence et
d'ailleurs on commence c'est une
expérimentation qui a commencé en 2009
alors la crise sanitaire évidemment un
peu retardée la mise en pratique puisque
les acteurs concernés ont été
occupés par bien d'autres tâches mais on
commence effectivement à observer des
effets alors c'est plutôt des
territoires sous dotés en professionnels
qui sont concernés aujourd'hui parce que
ils ont peut-être pas le choix en fait
que de travailler ensemble compte tenu
de la densité tant au niveau hospitalier
que qu'au niveau libéral mais c'est bien
tout l'enjeu effectivement d'éviter des
passages aux urgences dans des
conditions sanitaires pour la personne
et pour la collectivité extrêmement
dégradée donc oui l'objectif est bien
partagé merci pour terminer alors elle
s'appelle Honor va une question c'est
très rapidement parce que vous avez
répondu déjà à la question de ma
collègue sur les urgences c'est vrai que
on est très inquiet sur les territoires
enfin moi je suis sénatrice de la
Mayenne et il y a beaucoup beaucoup
comment de réactions par rapport aux
fermetures des urgences et je me pose la
question comment allons-nous
bien communiquer auprès de la population
parce que on voit bien d'une part que
nous aurons du mal à recruter des
urgentistes au vu de la situation qui
est
difficile et donc qui n'attire pas en
termes d'attractivité et ensuite parce
que on a tous fait les diagnostics je ne
sais combien de plans sur les urgences
mais cette réforme va-t-elle répondre
réellement à la problématique on sait
tous qu'il y avait des gens qui
n'avaient rien à faire aux urgences mais
qui ont voilà souvent
comment dirais-je pas trouver de réponse
aussi sur le terrain notamment par
rapport à l'accès aux soins donc comment
bien communiquer et comment répondrai
réellement aux situations d'urgence
vitale et il y a beaucoup de messages
qui sont contradictoires dans dans
dans les médias donc comment peut-on
faire les uns et les autres et aller
dans le même sens en terme de
communication
bon beaucoup de gens n'ont pas trouvé
mais aussi beaucoup on le réflexe
urgence tout de suite alors qu'il y a
parfois une permanence des soins sur le
territoire mais c'est pas la majeure
partie mais c'est quand même une partie
non négligeable alors Monsieur geprat
pour la faire et puis je sais pas si je
pourrais répondre à votre question sur
la communication sur les urgences mais
j'essaierai d'en parler à la fin de mon
propos concernant leurs dames donc je
partage qui a été dit notamment sur la
vision nationale nécessaire de
notification d'une politique publique
mais aussi sur la nécessaire
territorialisation de la gouvernance du
système il y a ici ou là des tentatives
de modification de cette vision
territoriale dont on l'appelle très
fortement de nos vœux et on pense que
c'est un vrai levier d'action dans la
mesure où on aurait un pilotage unifié
au niveau des territoires qui associe
aussi les collectivités et tous les
opérateurs quel que soit leur statut y
compris les opéras la médecine libérale
pour le dire très clairement on je crois
qu'on recrée un certain nombre de silos
aujourd'hui qu'on essaie de dessiloter
avec des systèmes postnr cts etc
on a l'impression que ça ça vient encore
s'empiler sur des dispositifs existants
et donc autant effectivement
l'organisation financière enfin le
fléchage financier peut être un outil un
levier puissant autant un pilotage plus
plus unifié entre secteurs sanitaires et
médico-social en particulier nous
paraîtrait une réponse pour
arriver aux objectifs qui sont
partiellement atteints avec les
enveloppes de dotation populationnelle
etc sur le sur le sujet de
l'harmonisation des charges on y est
plus que favorable on a construit des
coefficients de minoration pour tenir
compte des différences entre les
différents secteurs on a des difficultés
d'application de la fiscalité locale
pour nos établissements expliquent
notamment sur Taxe Foncière taxe
d'habitation
qui commence à devenir un sujet
important qui qui est assez nouveau mais
sur lequel on a des redressements ou des
demandes de la part de notre fédérale de
nos adhérents de conseils sur la
conduite à tenir donc ça on est
évidemment très demandeur d'une d'une
nouvelle approche sur ces sur ces sujets
sur le sujet de la formation
sénatrice ou si tu es des modèles
innovants alors nous on est persuadé que
c'est par là que passera une rénovation
de notre attractivité alors ça veut dire
aussi des outils de formation qui soient
rénovés dans leur plateforme et leur et
leur contenu pédagogique on sait que
notamment sur le paramédical il y a sans
doute des choses à faire je sentis qui
était ouvert sur le métier on peut
espérer que la formation en fera partie
la promotion professionnelle alors oui
pour des établissements privés comme les
nôtres qui cotisent un OPCO c'est un peu
plus compliqué de faire financer
massivement la promotion professionnelle
contenue du coup de cette dernière pour
une infirmière doit être à 80000 euros
pour passer d'aide-soignant infirmier
c'est que c'est considérable il y a des
avancées sur les as qui pourront passer
être dispensés d'une année via la VAE
c'est sans doute pas suffisant nous on
souhaiterait pouvoir développer plus
massivement l'apprentissage notamment
qui nous paraît être un levier puissant
d'être activité y compris pour les plus
jeunes puisqu'on a une difficulté sur le
sens et sur la vocation des métiers des
métiers du soin aujourd'hui et je
rejoins le la remarque de Cécile sur la
troisième la deuxième ou la troisième
partie de carrière ils sont des sujets
où on sait qu'à 50-55 ans c'est
compliqué de demander la même chose
qu'il y a des aides-soignantes qui en
ont qui en ont 20 compte tenu de la
l'engagement nécessaire auprès auprès
des malades enfin sur les sur les
urgences là encore une des solutions ou
est aussi le problème c'est là encore le
secteur médico-social qui est un
pourvoyeur de patients très important
aux urgences et qui peut être aussi dans
l'autre sens un bête bloqueur puisque si
les patients ne trouvent pas de solution
pour sortir de l'hôpital bah ils vont y
rester et donc ils vont emboliser le
système donc on croit beaucoup à des
dispositifs de détection des fragilités
et à aller vers les EHPAD à les Verts
les domicile ou un renforcement de
l'aide à domicile pour détecter les
fragilités et éviter
l'hospitalisation on peut aussi
travailler c'est déjà le cas sur des
admissions directes qui ne passent pas
par les urgences pour les patients qui
le nécessitent bien évidemment
ces dispositifs ils existent il faut il
faut sans doute les renforcer il faut
sans doute aider aussi les EHPAD pour
pas les citer à ne pas avoir le
transfert trop facile mais pour ça il
faut que les EHPAD puissent être
outillés et un minimum
paramédicalisé s'il y a pas de personnel
paramédical dans les États dans les
EHPAD on n'arrivera pas à maintenir des
des résidents qui sont un peu fragilisés
dans les établissement plutôt que de les
envoyer aux urgences avec les
conséquences qu'on connaît
merci beaucoup
pour cette cette éclairage qui est une
bonne préparation
cette réforme on verra en interrogera
demain le ministre brune puisqu'on le
reçoit demain matin mais ce sera je
pense une bonne préparation pour le
PLFSS et d'avoir eu l'éclairage des
non
l'éclairage des fédérations merci
beaucoup merci de votre disponibilité
toujours fidèle
tous les ce qui est bien c'est que vous
venez vous êtes toujours tous ensemble
en ayant des profils d'établissement
très différents